we need to now think about well okay how
do you choose these values here because
I just sort of plucked out negative 2
and negative 3 right where'd they come
from right there are two main principles
that you want to end these actually
worth writing down so maybe you want to
put like an arrow out of this box and
let's say principles for choosing values
a test
not the person the idea okay so you do
have to choose these values okay and you
can choose poorly so let me try to
explain there are two main values okay
the first one is here is the easy one of
the second one is the one that causes
the problems I think the first principle
is um truth values that are going to be
easy for you pick easy values now what
is it easy value what easily values are
whole numbers easy values are 0 but
things are when you are going to
evaluate them they are simple when we
get to trig functions right whole
numbers probably not so useful multiples
of 5 or nice fractions of pie they will
do things for you right or like 30-45
exact values you I mean so you want to
pick values that make the evaluation of
this number because you need a number on
you want to pick them city okay so
that's the first thing negative 2
negative 3 they fall into that category
okay however secondly you have to pick
them knew by now undeliverable a word
that is non-technical because there's no
like we're doing mathematics so that it
works not so that it follows arbitrary
rules okay and the word new buyer is
exactly right I in fact sometimes this
box is called a neighborhood test
because like just tell me what's
happening in but in the whole Bible is
not my name okay now what we want to
know is is this this is the kind of
picture we're trying to get now when you
say this one right this is in fact what
we had over there okay what we have here
it's sort of doesn't matter how far you
go this direction it's always going to
be negative on the left and it's always
gonna be positive on the right does that
make sense so really there you just pick
something easy right I could have I
could have put 0 that's to the right of
negative two and a half does that make
sense the magic really easy value to
test however here is why you need to
pick nearby these situations here I mean
they're the ones i adjure
to make it almost easy for you ah the
simplest that things get the things I'm
not usually like this functions more
frequently especially the interesting
person that you're going to be working
with they look more like this okay now
this is my this is my avenue to
introduce some other language which is
important to us and we'll come back and
we'll add under here but first let's
have a look at this when I soul for this
right when I solved for this yo you
don't know what function this is but how
many solutions were there me I want on
every spot where if I drew attention
there and be horizontal so for example
here's one right and then here's another
one and then here's another one and then
here's another one so just add a pinch i
would guess this is a quick look x to
the 5 and some extra for wasn't bad at
all okay so there will be four solutions
to this ok now let's just really quickly
imagine if i'm looking at this one and I
want to test I want to determine its
nature right now just supposing if the x
value is something like x equals one at
that spot you can clearly see if I go
too far to the right right my science
which at the moment go back to
greenville bring it I negative negative
negative 0 positive positive positive
positive if I go far enough if I go out
of the neighborhood for instance over
here I could test and say oh look it's
negative to the left and then it's
negative to the right I know what that
is that's a horizontal point of
inflection it's this kind right or
alternatively if I test it too far to
the left I could say hey look over here
on the left of my stationary point it's
positive and then am I going over here
it's also positive again I've got a
wrong kind of identification of what
type of stationary point laughter okay
so you can see here when you got other
stationary points clouding things up you
cannot afford to go too far okay now
therefore you will see sometimes you
know how I said x equals 1
right I've seen I've seen some people
insist that you have to test on the left
and right nor fair lawn then 0.1 ok now
this flies right in the face of
principle one of choosing values to test
kits like a verse can you pick something
harder yes a canvas and more decimal
places dynamic decimal places but my
point is like in some ways I even if I
says you were point nine and one point
one I could still make a function that
looked like this right I'll good they
look like this all right and it doesn't
matter if you went point one off still
too far away being that any function can
be designed such that no matter how how
close in you get but you could steal
oops go past another stationary point
that's really the problem with these
points over here do you see that if this
is the point you're interested in
testing if i go here the reason there's
a problem is because I pass this
stationary point or the reason that's a
problem is i pass the stationary point
you can make that arbitrarily small okay
so this note there's a very hard and
fast definition for this okay I know
every based on the fact that this is a
quadratic now you're too [ __ ] turn off
fine okay um there's no like little bit
like oh ok this is all right the same
time like there are values that are
obviously too far away like two and a
half more units like how far do you want
to go is gonna go test it 100 or
something so if you can get a bit
ridiculous I said I was going to use
this is my opportunity for talking about
just adding a tiny bit of extra language
here once you have this picture in your
mind okay you reset okay we've got
minimal take points where you go max an
attorney points right but when you look
at my for turning point situation over
here right which one is the minimum
there's a lot of
now you could you could argue you can
it's not a bad argument now this is the
minimum over here it's certainly at
least how I brought it there's certainly
lower than this one right but then again
who says this should be the move because
I have kind of like an infinite number
of values over here that are all lower
than your minimum right so therefore
calling either of those minimums
minimott by the way that's the parole is
kind of a bit of a hat right like
there's actually plenty of values
outside of here which we're also
interested in so to catch this language
to catch it and sort of explain the fact
that it is still a point I'm interested
in right you come back over here right
the actual mineral and max maximum when
describing over here what we call either
local remember how I talked about our
neighborhood right so it's like just in
this little spot in this little patch of
the function over here within that small
domain and there's no hard and fast
definition for small in the neighborhood
this is the minimum like this is the
lowest you can get like right there ok
our locals a bit of a bit of a
geographical work I think a better word
is relative ok so for instance I could
say you know the relative maximum height
in this room is my cattle a 186 ok
pretty tall but if we go to you know an
NBA game in the US okay then um that
local maximum will very very quickly
being exceeded right so relatively
speaking relative to all of us here in
this room ok that's the maximum all the
minimum right now being a local and
relative you also sometimes can have the
actual maximum or the actual minimum no
exceptions right so what could be the
opposite in its local rather just here
so there's everywhere generally we use
double
but what if wave you are rule then look
then Ruiz local okay anymore sign around
and up opposite of relative an absolute
having a good day okay sure so we might
have for instance just these guys these
guys are the relative minimum and a
relative maximum but then if we restrict
the domain we could get a global
absolute okay